it's not just the verbal gas joe biden
also seems to be having trouble with
something called
telling the truth because today biden's
out there claiming
his multi-trillion dollar tax hike it
won't cost
anybody anything nothing
take a look we got to compete
and it doesn't cost anybody anything and
deprive anybody of anything they
have earned or deserve as i said
we're now at a place where when they
used to pay 35
it's now 21. the way i can pay for this
is the 40 billion dollars for example
just making sure the largest companies
don't pay zero
and reducing the the uh
the tax cut to between 25 and 28
it's a couple hundred billion dollars we
can pay for these things
i'm not talking about deficit spending
i'm talking about paying for i won't go
i realize i'm getting too wonky shared
giving you too much detail
no i actually think joe probably
graduated from one of the many failed
public
high schools in states that have run by
his fellow democrats for decades because
he's pushing for higher income taxes for
those making
two hundred thousand dollars a year
along with the higher capital gains tax
and the higher corporate tax
and that corporate tax rate that always
get passed gets passed on to we
the people you the consumer under
biden's plan everybody will pay the
price
we'll all pay a ton more to fill up our
tanks heat and cool our homes
but don't worry democrats they know how
to spend your money
best look at your screen here are a few
examples of the requests from democrats
and the new
spending bill that brings us so
somewhere near 6 trillion in spending
1.75 million for the japan
institute in portland very needed
necessary
two million dollars for a pickleball
center
in orange california that's very
important for the pickleball players
1 million plus for a statute in sheila
jackson lee's district in texas
i thought we were done with statues
we're tearing them down now we're
building them up again several million
for new planned parenthood locations in
california
two million for a picnic area uh a park
area in california what what are those
benches made from gold
and we can go on and on but tonight the
biggest concern inside the democratic
party is not that joe biden will lie
about these radical spending proposals
and tax hikes
it's that he'll actually tell the truth
and that's why well press secretary
circle back jen saki just admitted that
the administration
constantly recommends that by not take
questions from reporters
here's her admonition he takes questions
nearly every day he's out from the press
that is not something we recommend
in fact a lot of times we say don't take
questions you know but he's going to do
what he wants to do because he's the
president of the united states
why why don't they recommend because oh
no they're oh please
just just get out of there quick before
something bad happens as usual
joe be a good president well if you're a
good president and you shut up
we'll reward you with cookies and warm
milky before your bedtime
somewhere around 7 p.m eastern we hear
now if this admission is not clear
confirmation the administration
is strategically hiding the president
from the public and the media
well what else is now if america had a
nonpartisan and irresponsible any fair
and a balanced
press this would be a big story it was
about donald trump it'd be a huge story
but we don't have an honest press in
america instead we have an abusively
biased corrupt media mob they protect
all things democratic
socialists green new deal socialists
they attacked every republican
especially if you say a good word about
donald trump
and of course this is a common theme on
joy
reid's sparsely watched show on msdnc
for example
last night one of her guests actually
claiming that the gop
is a bigger threat than al qaeda osama
bin laden
and the taliban combined
wow that's a record take a look i've
been thinking to myself this whole time
you know al qaeda osama bin laden
the taliban the people who wanted to do
harm to our nation
and to our way of life and our democracy
they got nothing
on what this republican party is doing
we are a two-party system in this
country
that's how it was built for better or
worse when one of those two parties
becomes this
radicalized and the core of the party's
ideology
is anti-democratic that is a very
dangerous development going on that's
going to result in more violence
it's going to result in more attempts to
overthrow our government that's going to
result in people
losing lives tom brokaw i know you're
retired
i wish you the best in your retirement
you've got to be so
proud of this news brand nbc news that
you spent an entire career building up
only to be shattered in mere moments now
you see what's happening here
on the left you're allowed to lie and
make crazy
ridiculous totally insane untrue
statements
and you can get a free past and you can
even
oh let's say racist things or racial
things
sexist things xenophobic homophobic and
you'll even get a pass if you're
a democrat and you can get away with
also calling
african-american conservatives pretty
much any name you want we saw that
recently with senator tim scott
but if you're on the right if you're a
conservative or a republican
no mistakes don't ever misspeak in fact
sometimes when you even tell the truth
you risk getting canceled anyway and
sometimes just existing
as a conservative in this pc world we
live in is enough to get everybody
banished
now this week congresswoman stefanik's
communications director suspended from
twitter
for apparently following too many
conservative accounts too quickly how
dare
that person do this her account was
later reinstated
and twitter now claims they made a
mistake at jack you have no credibility
with anybody
i'll be honest i don't believe you
twitter also suspending an account that
appeared to be linked to president
trump's
new communications platform from the
desk of donald j
trump as it turns out the twitter
account was reportedly not
created by anyone on the president's
team but just to be safe
twitter is still blocking the account
also this week
facebook extended their ban of the
former president indefinitely
now trump's former chief of staff mark
meadows warning that the partisan
actions of facebook
twitter will one day have dire
consequences for these big media tech
giants but how and when hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else